if we have this scaredness that many
young people now have
it's obvious you think i'm going to die
in 10 years there is no other problem
it's like a meteor hurtling towards
earth and the only thing to do is to you
know send off bruce willis on a on a
spaceship and and try to deflect it and
do nothing else but of course the
reality is this is one of the many
problems we need to fix in the 21st
century it's by no means the biggest
it's one of the many and we should fix
it smartly but we should remain calm
[Music]
welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show joining us on the line is bjorn
lomberg president of the copenhagen
consensus visiting fellow at the hoover
institution stanford university his
latest book false alarm how climate
change panic costs us trillions hurts
the poor and fails to fix the planet
bjorn thanks so much for joining the
show really appreciate it ben it's great
to be back so obviously we have the
global climate conference in glasgow it
is happening in november that is coming
up and we are in the ramp up stage of of
global warming paranoia and panic it is
astonishing that every year around this
time there seems to be this this vast
surge of stories about how climate
change is going to kill us all and it's
not that climate change isn't the thing
that's happening as you point out
repeatedly or as i pointed out
repeatedly it's that climate change is
happening and it's going to have some
deleterious effects those deleterious
effects are going to happen over the
course of the century most of them are
things that we can control for as humans
who are very very good at adaptation so
why all of the outsides panic and does
that have more to do with sort of an
underlying global agenda well it's very
clear that the alarm is very much
manufactured as you point out global
warming is a real problem global warming
will have negative impacts that's why
it's a problem but the end of the world
it both means that we end up spending
resources really badly because we're
panicked but of course also it has
tremendous impact on people's lives uh
look at all the young people who
literally believe that life is over for
them uh you know they're like why should
i go to school when life is going to end
in 10 or 20 years that's a terrible
outcome and it's also incorrect and i've
been battling this in a lot of different
ways simply trying to say look you've
got to look at the data you have to look
at what are the facts not just what
feels right
yeah
it seems that the climate change sort of
hysterics crowd uh instead of taking a
solid look at the data they would prefer
never to take a look at the data which
is why their spokes people generally are
not scientists their spokes people
generally are children or or barely
non-children like greta tunberg so for
years we heard that greta was
disappointed in us and if greta was
disappointed in us then this meant that
we obviously had to do more she never
called for anything particularly
specific other than apparently wrecking
the world economy um but because she was
a child and because she sailed from
sailed the atlantic to to come to the
united states and talk rather than
taking a jet this meant that she was a
credible source with regard to global
warming i've yet to hear any explanation
of what her policies would actually
accomplish but i guess that when you put
talking faces on tv yelling at you then
this is supposed to what jog the western
world into giving up all economic
development which by the way is the
chief method by which environmentalism
actually starts to matter to people is
when you're developed enough to actually
care about the environment it is a an
astounding fact and and i think it's
worth the step back well i think greta
is is a very good example of what very
many young people that i meet are
incredibly worried i understand why
she's worried you know if you just read
the press it feels like this is the end
of the world and and she's not wrong in
saying look you're not living up to your
promises because politicians have
promised vastly more than they're
actually going to deliver because as you
point out that would be phenomenally
expensive but and i think this is
important we need to give these young
people and of course everyone the good
data to understand that while this is a
problem it's not the end of the world so
one of the things i've i've pointed out
is that we know for instance with rising
temperatures you're going to see more
heat depth that's a real problem but
with rising temperatures you're also
going to see fewer cold deaths and just
remember
cold deaths vastly outweigh heat deaths
so there's about six hundred thousand uh
uh heat deaths in the world there's 4.5
million coal deaths over the last 20
years a new study in the landsat
estimate that the temperature rises that
we've seen over the last those last 20
years increased heat deaths but
decreased cold deaths much more such
that today
every year we save 166
000 people from dying because of the
higher temperature this is not the end
of the world this is actually a net
positive now in the long run that's
probably not going to stay like that it
is not the only impact of global warming
but this is exactly what you don't see
in the headlines you just hear
oh my god more people are going to die
from heat which is true but you don't
hear many fewer people are going to die
from cold you need to hear the whole
picture in order to not be alarmed in
order to be well informed and beyond one
of the things that drives me crazy about
this particular sort of conversation is
that if you want nobody to die of heat
or cool deaths uh then it turns out that
we have solutions for that in developed
countries they're called heating and air
conditioning and as you become much more
developed economically you tend to have
very few heat deaths and very few cold
deaths and when there is a a heat wave
like there was in france a few years
back and a bunch of elderly people died
in their apartments it's because they
did not have sufficient air conditioning
not just because it was hot outside uh
if you if you wish to relegate most of
the world's population to the abject
penury that getting rid of carbon-based
fuels in the way that greta tunberg
calls for would actually happen you're
talking about a lot more people dying
exactly so what you need to recognize is
that in rich countries as you mentioned
for instance in the u.s we have studies
back from early 1900s uh us now sees
more heat waves than they did in the
first part of the century and yet you
have many fewer people dying from heat
deaths because you have air conditioning
it's really not very complicated as you
mentioned in france in 2003 you had this
huge uh heat wave that killed lots and
lots of uh especially old people in
paris and the main reason of course was
that they didn't have any access to cool
air now they put in air conditioners in
most uh uh old people's home and they
had a higher and bigger heat wave they
had many many fewer deaths
actually it turns out that we're not
nearly as good at fixing coal deaths for
a simple reason heat death is something
that happens within a few days so you
simply need to open up your malls and
make sure that everybody gets their
access to air conditioning but cold
deaths happen because you don't have
access to heat at homes well-heated
homes for months and for many people
that's actually turning out to be very
hard to do because it's costly and as
you point out with climate policies
it'll get costlier yet and so you
actually see that many developing uh
developed countries have successfully
reduced heat deaths but they have not
gotten cold deaths under control in the
u.s for instance cold deaths are
actually rising and very likely to a
large extent because people can't afford
to keep their homes well uh heated we'll
get to more on this in just one second
first you may have noticed that the
global pandemic has completely disrupted
the markets reckless spending from
pelosi and biden that's making things
worse finding good places to invest your
hard-earned hundred thousand dollar
nested it can be tougher than ever if
you're like me or the rest of america
you're probably heavily allocated to
equities which is exactly what every
report from the wall street journal to
city is telling you probably not to do
at this point they're projecting equity
returns anywhere from five percent to
actually going negative with the fed
printing trillions of bucks on
congress's monstrous infrastructure bill
it doesn't take a genius to see your
money needs a safe haven it needs it
right now so how are professional
investors preparing for this nightmare
scenario well many of them already have
they've turned to an under the radar
asset class one that has historically
only been available to coastal elites
and hedge fund managers it's a real
physical asset it's not gold or real
estate or crypto it's actually fine art
it's one of the oldest most stable asset
classes of all time thanks to a new
revolutionary tech platform you can
finally get access to this exciting six
trillion dollar world early adopters
have already returned 32
on their investment and the waitlist
keeps getting longer lucky for you
they've given me 60 passes to just skip
that to jump to the front of the line
head on over to masterworks dot io slash
ben that is masterworks dot io slash ben
previous offers have sold out now or
don't wait around before deciding to
invest carefully review the important
disclosures at masterworks dot io slash
disclaimer we're speaking with bjorn
lomberg he of course is at the
copenhagen consensus and visiting fellow
hoover institution his book is false
alarm so
bjorn one of the other issues that has
come up a lot in the united states
recently is the wildfire issue so we've
seen extensive wildfires in the west i
was recently in sacramento the air
quality is just terrible over there
because of the wildfires that they've
had there throughout the summer and of
course the governor of california has
said he now wants to spend 15 billion
dollars on various climate projects well
i mean the the reality is that as
everybody who's watched this stuff knows
it is it is the foresting policy of the
west that has largely led to the vast
increase in acreage that's been burned
recently it is true that global warming
makes things hotter it makes things
drier it means that the brush is going
to dry out faster but there's a pretty
easy way of preventing the sort of
devastating wildfires that you've seen
in places ranging from wyoming and
montana to california and that is to
have a not crappy forest policy
yes so fundamentally this is mostly
about making smarter forest management
it's about uh
burning uh controlled burns so you don't
have this buildup of under bush you
don't have this immense buildup of
biomass uh and and there's also this
funny and strange thing and and mostly
misinforming thing that people shift
their focus constantly to where it's
burning most and saying see
uh a little bit like you know when
people were talking about the very real
heat deaths and at the uh at the heat
dome in in california sorry in
in the northwest u.s and canada uh
earlier this year uh but failing to
remember all the cold deaths that they
don't report on and that are actually
declining dramatically the same way
in most of the world we've actually seen
declining levels of fire so globally
fire has declined to last 120 years
because we're adaptive species that know
how to make sure
it doesn't burn because for most people
they don't actually want stuff to burn
now some places as you mentioned in in
the u.s
west they have not done so to a very
large extent they've made very bad
forest policies and now we're seeing uh
uh forced fire levels going back up not
quite to where they were before
pre-history so before 1800 but certainly
much higher up but remember the if you
look at the u.s average fire it's
actually according to the u.s own
statistics it's lower than uh than the
average of the last 20 years it's not
higher but you focus on some areas and
look that does not mean that this is not
a problem if you live in some of these
areas obviously you want this fixed but
there's something absurd about saying
all right it's burning here so i'm gonna
drive an electric car what no you should
ask your governor and you should ask
policymakers to make prescribed burns
you should make something that'll
actually have a significant impact not
make stuff that will at best have a
marginal impact in 100 years yeah this
is one of the things that drives me
absolutely crazy if you got rid of all
of the gas powered vehicles on the road
in the united states the amount of
damage reduction you would do from
climate change is absolutely minimal
over the course of the century because
the fact is that energy production is
being done all over the world actually
gas-powered vehicles are a pretty small
percentage of overall carbon emissions
even though the media portrays them as
the largest percentage of carbon
emissions and and the reality is that
again america people generally are very
very good at adaptation a good example
of this is the hurricane that hit the
southern united states and then made its
way up through the northeast over the
past couple of months it hit the exact
same area as as hurricane katrina did
and it did a minimum of damage and the
reason that it did a minimum of damage
is because the governors of the states
and the and the federal government
actually did their job and short up the
infrastructure in precisely those areas
so very similar hurricane very different
results that has nothing to do with
global warming that has to do with
humans actually doing their jobs exactly
and and we need to know this in a more
general fashion that because people get
richer they're hurt much less by
whatever nature throws at them when you
put it like this it's almost obvious but
if you actually look at the data so we
have good data back from 1920 uh from
the international disaster database for
all climate-related disasters of floods
droughts storms uh wildfires and
extreme temperatures and their estimate
is
that over the last 100 years we've gone
from a situation where on average
every year about half a million people
died from climate related disasters
last decade in 2010
it was down to below 20 000 so about 18
000.
this year
if we assume that the year is going to
end like all other years given the data
that we already have it will be about 6
000 people we've seen a reduction
of 99. something depending a little bit
on what you think so a dramatic
reduction and remember at the same time
uh global population is quadrupled so
what we've really seen is an
extraordinary reduction in
death risk from climate-related
disasters this has nothing to do with
climate change it has everything to do
with the fact that people are much
richer and that's why you've got to ask
yourself when very excited green uh uh
campaigners tell us you've got to cut
your carbon emissions to help those poor
people in you know tackle iran for the
philippines or wherever but the reality
is if you want to help poor people get
them out from corrugated roofs and
poverty and you make sure that they get
so rich that they become florida because
when a hurricane hits florida sure
there's lots of damage but very few
people die if the same hurricane hits
guatemala it damages their economy and
it kills tens of thousands of people i
mean this is exactly right we live in
florida and we have things called
hurricane windows they're they're
they're very they're extremely heavy the
glass is very heavy we we have our
roofing taken care of regularly we have
a generator right we have specific
provisions that we've been able to make
via the power of money in order to
insulate ourselves from the possible
damage of a hurricane and even if there
were a category 5 hurricane we could
then get on these things called planes
and we could fly to another place where
the hurricane is not so that we wouldn't
be directly in the path of the hurricane
and people do this every year down here
in florida and we choose to live here
but we choose to live here because we
could do all those things if it were
your choices you get to live in kansas
in a shack or in florida in a shack
you'd be an idiot not to
to live in florida on the beach in a
shack right i mean that'd just be a dumb
thing to do because you just don't have
the ability to protect yourself in the
same way but but we don't thank god we
have to do that because of the magic of
prosperity this is something that
william nordhaus has talked about
extensively he won the nobel prize for
it and then all of his work subsequently
seems to be ignored because
his his work nordhaus's work is
predicated on the assumption that
economic growth over the course of the
next century is going to continue and
that therefore we actually have to game
out what level of economic damage will
be done such that we ought to be worried
about climate change beyond a particular
point but the climate change sort of
radicals have suggested that any amount
of climate change is is bad and
therefore nordhaus's work has sort of
almost fallen out of fashion these days
specifically because he says things like
you know if it's below two degrees
celsius you're probably mitigating a
problem that is you're creating a
problem that's larger than the one
you're mitigating exactly i mean and
this is the older they change the cure
should not be more costly than the
affliction that you're trying to fix you
shouldn't cure a risk take by chopping
off your arm
and and in many ways that's exactly what
we're suggesting uh look climate change
will have real costs so north house and
many many others and this is also the
last u.n uh climate report uh u.n
climate panel report estimates that if
we do nothing about global warming the
cost by the end of the century will be a
reduction in gdp of about you know three
four percent let's say 3.6 that's uh the
central estimate 3.6
that means
because we're going to be much richer
we're actually going to be about 450
richer than we are today uh that means
we'll only be 400
434 as rich as we are today uh
yeah it's a little problem it's not the
end of the world and that's why you
should do some things you should do
smart climate policies but you should
not do dumb climate policies you should
not do too much because then you
actually leave the future worse off you
leave people with less opportunities and
it's the classical argument that you
have to realize climate change is not
the only problem out there
most people have many other problems
like how do i pay for my health care how
do i pay for my heating bill how do i
pay for all these other things that i
want and i need and education what have
you and you need to make sure you
maximize across all these areas not just
say i want to spend everything and the
kitchen sink on fixing climate change
but unfortunately we can't have that
conversation if we don't have the
numbers if we have this scaredness that
many young people now have
it's obvious you think i'm going to die
in 10 years there is no other problem
it's like a meteor hurtling towards
earth and the only thing to do is to you
know send off bruce willis on a on a
spaceship and and try to deflect it and
do nothing else but of course the
reality is this is one of the many
problems we need to fix in the 21st
century it's by no means the biggest
it's one of the many and we should fix
it smartly but we should remain calm
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first we've got a different kind
of sponsor for this particular episode
it's called the jordan harbinger show
it's a podcast you should be listening
to i know every day somebody tells you
you have to listen to some podcast or
other and you're not you're like yeah
sure and then you never listen to it
don't let that happen here we are fans
here at the daily wire jordan's show
which apple named one of its best of
2018 is aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain each episode is a
conversation with a different
fascinating guest when i say there's
something for everyone i really mean it
in one episode jordan talks to a hostage
negotiator from the fbi who offers
techniques on how to get people to like
and trust you that's useful but also
somewhat disturbing also another episode
tells the story of a pimp and mafia
enforcer who talks about mind
manipulation techniques and how we can
defend against them there are other
episodes including people like scott
adams or jack schaefer or oliver north
maybe even dan carlin or kobe bryant i
don't always agree with jordan but he's
a sharp guy and he gives great advice i
learn a lot every time i listen if
that's not worth checking out i'm not
sure what is there's a lot here check
out jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h a r b as in boy i n is a nancy
g e r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts so bjorn
it seems to me that so much of what is
going on right now honestly is just
politicians attempt to evade all sorts
of of basic responsibilities we saw this
after the hurricane that uh that ended
up causing some flooding in new jersey
and new york state uh there are
politicians out there every day of the
week chuck schumer the mayor of new york
bill de blasio and you see this in the
summer from gavin newsom with the
wildfires
there's the politicians instead of
focusing on what they can do instead
what they tend to do is say things like
well you know global warming man and we
better focus in on global warming like a
laser that means spending trillions and
trillions of dollars at the federal
level on global warming or we're going
to see more of this kind of stuff it
just seems like a very easy evasion for
folks if you can shift the problem to a
problem so large and unmanageable you
can never be blamed for it that it has
to be get china and india on board and
then we can solve this problem as
opposed to hey maybe we should you know
build a sea wall or something near miami
so that we don't get flooded then that
means you never have to be
there's no responsibility that attaches
your actual political position it's
certainly a way to deflect blame uh so
you know in germany when we heard about
all the uh flooding here which was
terrible and killed uh several hundred
people it is astounding that the main
problem the reason why so many people
died was that the alert system didn't
work people were supposed to get sms
messages text messages and get alerts
there was supposed to be sirens
almost none of it worked and of course
the politicians responsible for this
were saying not my fault it was global
warming's fault it's much easier but i
think there's a bigger part that plays
into
the fact that most politicians have to
promise you a lot of stuff in order to
win an election now that's hard to do
because you actually have to pay up and
and you can't you know just hand out
money uh eventually you run out of all
that money but what politicians have now
discovered is that with climate policy
you can promise that other people in the
long-term future are going to spend lots
and lots of money on things that you
don't actually have to oversee uh
remember uh angela merkel the the leader
of germany has you know been in politics
for 30 years and she's promised all
kinds of stuff in climate policy but now
she's leaving before the really hard
part comes and and you know pretty much
all the leaders at the paris uh climate
agreement have now left it's very very
easy to promise you're going to do stuff
far into the future and then somebody
else have to pay essentially we're uh
applauding them and we're
giving them votes because they promise
stuff that they were never going to
deliver in the first place that is what
we really need to make sure we catch
them on and say look you can't just
promise these
grand ideas uh 10 20 30 years out you
have to actually tell us what are we
going to do today and of course nobody
will actually gain
a a victory in an election if they
promise to
spike the gasoline price by another
couple of dollars that's bjorn lombard
his book is false alarm how climate
change planet costs us trillion
hurts the poor and fails to fix the
planet you should go check it out right
now so bjorn what can we expect from all
of these sorts of
climate conferences that are supposed to
crop up uh in the next couple of months
i would assume just more promises more
talk and then greta tinberg being
disappointed in us
in some ways she should because the
politicians are getting away with
claiming stuff that they will never
actually deliver but we are going to see
a lot of politicians promise stuff that
will be phenomenally costly if it's
actually done
so if you look here in europe
we're set to have a very tough winter
because we've basically
shifted a lot to renewables renewables
obviously don't deliver when the wind is
not blowing and the sun is not shining
so you need backup power typically from
gas
and we don't have enough gas it is very
likely that this could be a phenomenally
expensive uh winter and that of course
will lead to a lot of people saying
maybe we don't want all these climate
policies if they're leading to this
amount of of hurt and damage and
likewise in the u.s uh as biden is
promising to get to net zero by 2050
that will not only cost a phenomenal
amount of money so one study in nature
estimated that to reach almost his
target by 2050 will cost the average
american and remember again average
american each and every year by 2050
more than eleven thousand dollars per
person per year that's a lot of money i
think most politicians can say you're
never actually going to win elections
poisoning those kinds of of costs so
what we're basically seeing is lots of
people talking doing some of this and
that will be very costly it'll actually
garner very little climate benefit but
it will have real hurt that's a bad idea
because there are smarter ways as you
also pointed out the real way to fix
climate change like most other things is
through innovation if we could innovate
the price of new green energy that could
be solar panels with uh with batteries
or it could be a a
better
efficient or maybe even fusion energy or
some other idea if we could innovate
cheap green energy
everyone would buy not just rich
well-meaning americans but the chinese
and the indians as well as pioneer go
check out his brand new book false alarm
and all of his work over at the hoover
institution bjorn thanks so much for
your time i really appreciate it
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed